um we were sort of talking about this
sort of mini entrepreneurial nature of
it
uh of you know hair cutters uh
barbers hairstylists etc they all have
their own little businesses
they do they they are an entrepreneurial
bunch where they move from one salon to
another
they might change and say i got a better
deal here or they might then start their
own barbershop
you do see that path right in these
employees or these freelancers who then
become owners of businesses
all the time that that's that's kind of
the natural trajectory
um for a successful career um in this in
this industry is that
eventually many of them they want to
open the shop and that's the main way
that they can
you know build more wealth and and you
know make more money outside of just the
number of haircuts they're providing
each day so
absolutely we see that and so if they
were not 1099 employees they wouldn't be
as portable or flexible they wouldn't be
able to leave and go to work for another
one to start their own
they would just be hourly workers who
had to work specific shifts and that
would be
less that would give them less mobility
it would give them
probably less mobility and also it would
i think that's a type of model that
could work uh for some
barber shops that that have the
resources um
but you know like we said before
barbershop is a pretty easy business to
start
yeah you know and the overhead and the
amount of assets required is really low
and that's part of the one of the
appealing reasons of why there's so many
shops and why
this is interesting for for these these
business owners
if if you required all the barbership
employees it'd be a
really heavy lift i think just starting
a barber shop
um and getting it off the ground um so
you know we see that model more like in
the franchises
um that have you know 30 40 50. oh the
super cuts of the world
they pay people an hourly wage yeah they
pay people hourly but for the
so you have to be a shift worker you got
to work eight hour shifts when they tell
you
yeah and you got to do x number of hours
per week and you're not allowed to work
at another salon
yeah yeah they basically dictate your
entire work
yeah typically yeah i think this is the
important discussion that people don't
understand is that once you add all
these regulations
it becomes impossible for somebody if
they had to hire everybody full time and
take on that risk
to pop up a shop right um
yeah i mean i think it would it would be
um
i mean we can think of i'm sure there's
there's room to think of
how how it could be improved and how we
could provide some more safeguards
but for barbers outside of the current
situation but i definitely think it
would be
heavy-handed to require all barbers and
the employees we would see a lot of
stops shutting down most likely
yeah this is the thing i think there's
this good intention i think when people
think they're trying to protect workers
but i don't think that this class of
worker wants
to be forced to be an hourly worker they
the what do you see amongst that group
in terms of do they
want to be hourly workers or do they
just want to be
the freelancers the way they are if you
were to ask 10 of them how many would
say
i want the current system how many would
say they want to just
make the same amount of money but be
hourly yeah to be fair i haven't pulled
this
so i don't know for sure but and
anecdotally i would guess
that they like the current system
they want to be able to uh charge you
know
as much as possible make as much as
possible for the services they're
providing and have that kind of
flexibility
um and and they also like to build their
own book of business
uh many barbers um so they you know they
like to
think that you know these are their
customers that they've been building so
when they do go to another shop
um they can bring those you know
customers how do you do that with the
software i'm curious how do you manage
that with
people booking just the do they split
the ownership of that lead does the
individual barber get a copy of the
contact information and the
store or does the individual person have
to like build it up and build up their
own
phone book on their iphone various case
by case and
it depends on who how the shop is set up
so if they're if they're a booth rental
and each barber's really just an
independent business owner doing
doing their own thing generally they'll
have access to
the customer data and they can take it
with them when they're commissioned
when there's a commission shop and the
relationship is with the owner of the
shop and squire
in that case we kind of default to the
owner and and like how they want to run
it
um a lot of times the owners invest a
lot of money in marketing and branding
into you know acquiring these customers
so it's not really fair to them
uh to then have the barbers you know
take all that
business and leave within start a
competitor yeah across the street you
know which we've seen
a lot of times actually